the first night if I didn't want to stay
the first night why would I stay any
more than five why would I stay any more
than duello
go away nobody likes you yeah
so who's got a bad breath please up I
can do it but yes I'd like one that I
didn't even see chica coming huh that's
not a joke for the internet to enjoy
young about you're playing the banjo
there whatever it is I don't know
electric guitar or something what the
[ __ ] I'm so worried about frigging
Bonnie over there I was gonna die I was
bad
screw you I'm staying here
ah how am I gonna beat the first night
this is impossible
excuse me Barney that's very rude I just
ate before I did this God boobie boobie
boobie in my pants hihihihihi flashlight
what the hell no no no no no no no no no
no no
Oh God
memories memories memories I got it I
got it I got I got I got I so god I'm
still alone
I'm boned he's gonna kill me he's gonna
kill me
Oh Mike man hey dawn yeah
I don't yeah come on the black give our
baby Bobby loved it
oh god I'm bone oh god I'm bone the bone
come on come on come on come on pieces
hanging up there like a douche
hey holes are going there you want to
win too bad no no
huh you want to mess with the likes of
me I got a cracking voice I'm
practically messing hey whoa whoa oh now
that it's been confirmed that chicas
actually a girly girl has made the life
of me so fun
I don't know it'd be fun don't read too
much into that 1785 are you with you try
this take are you there you better not
be one what the [ __ ] I knew it oh my god
I'm alive hey what are you doing
we friendly hello hi hey how's it going
bro I'm gonna play hey what the [ __ ] is
that what am I gonna do what are you
okay bye
oh god damn it
I know ventilation air I know I know
Balloon Boy you're a dick
I get it remind me to punch you in the
face ten times more than usual
oh oh I'm Freddy whoa hey oh you know
what I just met your friends like chica
and blue boy came back together we had a
big gang bang together we had so much
fun in a big orgy pile with all the
spare parts
it was great let me tell you seven Oh No
the lights may be blaring but I'd like
to think about the red-hot burning love
that I feel in my heart for you yeah ha
ha ooh but you've duped you I love you
at all
damn fight back back back five - five
lakh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you you know what
I'm not even gonna be nice you [ __ ] you
and everything you care about or loved
or ever needed in your life I hope you
get nothing beneficial to you to advance
your career I hope you don't get that
promotion
I don't enjoy all the lovely things in
life I hope you don't see beaches and
travel around the world I hope you do
nothing oh [ __ ] well--there's why do I
only have two audio checks Perdue that
didn't make any sense but I'm trying not
to English here because I don't speak
English good and I don't English good at
all and I don't worry good [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
no not now I can only assume he's in
that one but now I know this is a guest
at this point it's just a theory
where'd he come from where'd he go
where'd he come from Ghana
for you oh my god it's not good
ah [ __ ] I'm so Bo so strongly Bo like I
really know my [ __ ] when it comes to
this game y'all yeah I've never used
that kind of lingo before but I'm
feeling slightly sassy
make it I'm making a call yeah how do I
get three you son of [ __ ]